in the modern era Batman is one of the
most popular superheroes to ever exist
in the history of DC Comics and I would
go so far as to argue he's more popular
than Superman
what's so funny about this is Batman is
not supposed to exist because there was
a time when DC Comics was gonna cancel
his comic book line and kill him off
forever
so when Batman first came onto the scene
in 1939 his stories were dark his early
comic saw him killing villains with
poison gas hanging mental patients from
the Batwing watching on while villains
burned to death and even showing the
Joker assassinating a political official
sure they were morally questionable acts
but as no kill rule had not been
established by this point and the
general argument was that the villains
had it coming anyway
but all of this changed in the mid to
late 1950s the reason for this was due
to a pseudopsychologist named Frederick
Wortham who published a book in 1954
called seduction of the innocent arguing
that comic books were corrupting
America's youth wortham's book drew the
attention of both the American people
and Casey kafar a senator from Tennessee
who saw the book as a rallying cry
as a result of the general Public's
reaction as well as his own political
aspirations Casey brought worth them
before the Senate subcommittee on
juvenile delinquency and wortham's
testimony nearly led to Congress passing
legislation that would have severely
restricted what could be published
within a comic book but despite the
testimonies of comic creators Publishers
and other psychologists who saw
wortham's book as an example of
cherry-picking data something had to be
done
so the comic industry chose to regulate
itself establishing the comics code
Authority the ins and outs of the
Commerce code are outside the scope of
this video but any comic that did not
contain the comics code seal of approval
would not be sold and among the various
rules of the comics code was the rule
that vigilantism could not be glorified
in depictions of extreme violence
couldn't be shown but what was Batman if
not a comic book character glorifying
violence and using extreme tactics so to
ensure that Batman comics could be sold
DC was forced to tone his character down
his dark and hyper-violent ways were
replaced with Goofy moments like the
rainbow and zebra Batman suits in
Detective Comics 241 and 275
respectively the sword fight between
Batman and Superman and world's finest
143 and the story of Batman wearing a
Jester hat and punching the side of a
building in world's finest 109. being
such a stark difference from the stories
that so many had grown up with meant
that Batman's audience had begun to
dwindle
fans were angry and they were betrayed
that the antithesis to Superman's Boy
Scout mentality had been reduced to a
goof but with their hands tied by the
comics code
what was DC Comic supposed to do
[Music]
the Adam West Batman show was actually
the Saving Grace that DC Comics needed
originally intended to be a juvenile
Adventure Show the television rights for
Batman shifted from CBS to ABC and then
eventually Fox who hired William Dozier
to produce the series but after reading
several of the existing Batman stories
under the rules of the comics code
Dozier decided to make the series campy
focusing more on nonsensical slapstick
humor but much like during the height of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe viewers
who had never read a Batman comic in
their life saw themselves flocking to
local stores to pick up the newest issue
of the cave Crusader and for a time
sales skyrocketed in fact between 1966
and 1968 when the show aired Batman's
Comics went from selling 400 000 issues
per month to almost nine hundred
thousand and it made perfect sense
the 1960s were a socially chaotic time
in America Society saw some of the
highest highs with NASA's Moon landing
in beetlemania but they also saw the
lowest lows with the civil rights
movement in JFK's assassination
these combined with the looming threat
of mutually assured destruction during
the Cold War myth of the American people
wanted an escape Adam West Bert Ward
Cesar Romero they all provided exactly
that but as the show went off the air in
1968 sales of Batman started to collapse
falling to 355 000 in 1969.
but by this point the comics code
Authority which had been this almost
omnipresent entity looming over both
creators and fans alike had now become
virtually toothless due to stories like
Green Lantern and green arrow snowboards
don't fly and Spider-Man's the Green
Goblin reborn both of which dealt with
the issue of drugs completely ignoring
the rules of the comics code
this matters because in 1971 Dennis
O'Neill and Neil Adams began their
legendary Batman run
While most people credit Neil and Adams
for taking Batman back to the old Bob
Kane Bill Finger darker stories in his
earlier Comics the significance of their
run is much bigger than that
unlike the comedic and Candy Batman of
the 1950s and 60s who came out on top
because of circumstance Dennis O'Neill
and Neil Adams had transformed Batman
into a kind of James Bond character the
story shifted their focus presenting a
more human infallible superhero that
relied more on his detective spy and
fighting abilities the more fallible
side was shown and that he could be
taken by surprise and beaten his
detective skills were showcased through
disguises and sleuth tactics while his
Human Side came in as empathy towards
any and all victims of crime
villains like razor ghoul were
introduced as a looming threat while
Neil and Adam stayed away from Batman's
traditional Rogues Gallery with the
exception of stories like Joker's
five-way revenge and half an evil which
saw the return of Two-Face after almost
17 years and all of these stories flew
in the face of the comics code helping
to shatter what little influence it had
left but despite the return to classic
Batman storytelling the sales of his
Comics continue to slip dropping from
200 000 issues per month in 1973 to 89
000 in 1985. this was compounded by the
overall DC Comics landscape and that the
Advent of the Multiverse and the Flash
of Two Worlds and the DC implosion of
1978 meant that for the average comic
reader entering the DC landscape meant
having to decipher the main Universe
from the varying alternate realities
figuring out where Batman resided within
the existing continuity as well as
sifting through the massive catalog of
DC Comics
in effect DC was almost impossible to
access if you were new to comic books
and so in an effort to reconcile their
Multiverse and clean slate their
landscape in 1985 DC launched crisis on
infinite Earth the purpose behind the
event was to eliminate the Multiverse
and then relaunch with a single Universe
known as New Earth where the various
characters of the DC landscape would
receive updated Origins and new number
ones giving new readers a fresh place to
start
but because of his low sales
Batman's future was up in the air
on one hand he'd been a staple of the DC
Universe for over three decades but on
the other his sales were low there were
no film or TV prospects on the horizon
to boost interest and crisis on infinite
Earth presented the best opportunity to
kill him off and cancel his comics
now it was around this time that Frank
Miller was working on both Daredevil and
the Wolverine miniseries of Marvel
Comics and while Marvel had its own
share of problems with Jim shooter as
the editor-in-chief Miller caught the
attention of Jeanette Khan the president
of DC and Dick Giordano the managing
editor for the entire Batman line in
truth Miller had no interest in writing
Batman and it actually wanted to focus
on Ronan a six issue miniseries with a
cyberpunk feel but to Jeanette and
Giordano a Batman story written in the
vein of Frank Miller's Daredevil was an
absolute no-brainer and so the three of
them struck a deal if Miller was willing
to write a Batman comic he'd have free
reign on Ronan and for Miller it was
solid pulling off a Batman story that
could return the character to the height
of his popularity would solidify his
name in the halls of comicton forever
and the icing on the cake was complete
creative freedom on a series of his own
making as opposed to the creative
limitations imposed by shooter and
Marvel
the other side of this was that if
Miller's story failed Batman was done
you're never a god
now a lot of discussions surrounding the
development of The Dark Knight Returns
Sinners on his influence from Dirty
Harry and Frank Miller building on the
old Bob Kane Bill finger and Dennis
O'Neal and Neil Adams runs but a
lesser-known influence for the story
came from Alan Moore's Watchman
much in the same way that Watchman was
Rife with political messages and themes
illustrating how superheroism can
consume change and break people the
bleakness of Watchmen is mirrored in The
Dark Knight Returns and that Gotham and
the world overall look and feel like a
very dark place Batman has long since
retired criminals have overrun the city
and Corruption is taken hold the Joker
returns and then basically kills himself
leading to a massive Manhunt for Batman
because everybody believes that he's the
one that killed the Joker and the story
culminates in one of the most
significant moments in DC Comics history
Batman fighting Superman
now for the non-comic reader this is
simply the first in what has become a
Mainstay battle between DC's most
popular Heroes but for the person who'd
been reading comics for decades this was
game changing
something to understand is that the
relationship between Batman and Superman
dates back to 1952 with Superman number
76 the mightiest team in the world prior
to this they were just two characters
published by the same comic book company
but crossing over in such a way now
meant that they shared a single universe
Gotham City was here Metropolis was over
there and so in the decades that
followed the team-ups between both these
Heroes had become so popular that DC
launched a series called world's finest
and while it initially contained
separate stories involving these guys it
evolved to Showcase Batman Superman and
occasionally Robin teaming up to fight
some foe the point that I'm making here
is that whether through some kind of
shared conflict or something as simple
as a cookout Batman and Superman were
viewed as friends but on a larger scale
Superman was untouchable from the
original Jerry Siegel and Joe Schuster
stories to the mort weissinger era of
the 1950s Superman was DC's Flagship an
Unstoppable Force standing for truth
justice and the American way he was a
hero who stood up for the Common Man
on the other hand Batman was just a guy
and a well-placed bullet from an
unsuspecting location would mean the end
of Bruce Wayne
and so for long time readers to crack
open a comic book and find that Superman
had become a government stooge and that
Decades of friendship had rotted away
leading to a fight among Titans with
Batman triumphant was unheard of
and they loved it
by 1987 Batman sales had skyrocketed
jumping to 193
000 per month Frank Miller followed this
story up with Batman year One a
retelling of Bruce Wayne's origin in the
post-crisis era and the Batman explosion
was on within three years Batman had
overtaken Superman in sales DC had
expanded its lineup to include Comics
like tales of the Dark Knight and Tim
Burton was directing a Batman film
and so while I believe that the current
work of riders in DC Comics cannot be
ignored especially considering Scott
Snyder's Landmark Batman run with the
new 52 in 2011. I think it's equally
important to stand up and say had it not
been for Dennis O'Neill Neil Adams and
Frank Miller Batman as we know him
simply wouldn't exist
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this video to an end if you're
interested in getting into Batman as a
come of a character make sure you click
this link and it'll take you to our
Batman playlist